vor rund einem Monat habe ich einen Ikea
Stuhl nachgebaut um zu schauen ob das
günstiger ist als das Original jetzt
habe ich Lust ein passendes Möbelstück
selbst zu designen gerade weil
designertische locker mal über 2000 €
Kosten außerdem soll mein Tisch genau
wie mein Bett mit Wireless charging und
LEDs wieder etwas Einzigartiges können
und in dem Fall ist das eine
eingelassene Metallleiste die als
Heizplatte dienen soll um Essen warm zu
halten oder aufzuwerfen direkt am Tisch
also habe ich mir auf einer Zugfahrt im
ICE quer durch Deutschland gedacht
konzentrierst Du Dir einfach deinen
eigenen Tisch als Inspiration dafür habe
ich mich auf Pinterest umgeschaut und
festgestellt dass ich einen schräge ist
und verrücktes Bein Gestell cool findet
das ist so ähnlich schon gibt aber
erstens ist das überall parallel wohin
gegen nicht das Kreuz und Quer viel
schicker finde und außerdem kostet es
einfach 750 €. ich bestelle also den
Stall fürs Gestell im Internet für rund
80 € und nochmal 20 € für den Stall für
die Heizplatte Manu organisiert eine
eichenholzplatte aus dem Baumarkt und
los geht's
dieses Video wird unterstützt von Intel
mehr dazu später diese fetten
Metallbeine die sollen ja so schräg sein
und dafür müssen jetzt erstmal
geschnitten werden unsere metallbandsäge
ist dafür einmal ein bisschen zu klein
mit der Flex wird auch gehen aber
einfach ewig dauern und unser
Schweißgerät
das kann auch Plasma schneiden und das
machen wir aber das geht richtig schnell
jetzt auch noch nie gemacht sind noch
ein bisschen gefährlich aber klingt auch
spaßig so einmal Winkel anzeichnen und
einmal durch zack das ist voll schief
geworden
am Ende einfach komplett schief ja gut
also das erste Mal Plasma Lasern
schneiden wow
[Musik]
Alter
komplett weg
ja
[Musik]
krass
und dann der letzte Schnitt und ich
finde tatsächlich dass es echt gut
irgendwie zusammengekommen ist und ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt so durchschneide
ein bisschen schräg aufhalte dann ist
das glaube ich ganz geil
so das ist ja scheiße weiß
das Holz drauf
im Boden brennt geil aber das ist
richtig schön geworden hey der schrägen
ist auch andere Seite also soll jetzt
89,7 cm lang werden das ist natürlich
super schwierig ist
89,7 und dann noch parallel dazu
anfangen und dann auf der anderen okay
Achtung
[Musik]
letztes Mal Vorsicht
und dieses Bein muss jetzt irgendwie ans
Holz dran gemacht werden und dafür mache
ich jetzt noch so eine Grundplatte die
da drauf kommt so von ausgehen jetzt 5
cm
[Musik]
jetzt werden wir wieder geschweißt das
heißt das Teil hier wo die Löcher drin
sind und man den Tisch dran zu schrauben
reduziert drauf weil das halt definitiv
hässlicher Seite ist hier ist super
schöne komm nach unten weil die sieht
man ja
[Musik]
ich habe das angerissen kann jetzt
einmal hier dran halten und mir einmal
mit dem Magneten hier festmachen perfekt
[Musik]
auch wenn es jetzt hier noch nicht ganz
dicht an dicht dran ist erstmal richtig
schön rankommen
[Musik]
okay das war richtig dumm
also sollte es nicht sein aber das hält
das bombenfest da dran sieht eh keiner
die andere Seite muss alles schöner
werden und dadurch natürlich nicht nur
ein Bein bekommen soll das ganze jetzt
noch mal dreimal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Beine hier die müssen jetzt an die
Tischplatte angeschraubt werden
allerdings habe ich dir ultra verrückt
angeordnet hier eine Konstruktion und
genauso muss das jetzt hier im Maske
treu drauf geschraubt werden damit sich
die ganzen Beine nicht in die Quere
kommen und nicht die Beine untereinander
zusammenschweißen kann ich arbeite
übrigens an meinem Internet evolut
Laptop mit dem ich den kompletten Tisch
auch designt habe wobei mir der verbaute
hinterkopf-prozessor der 12 Generation
geholfen hat ich bringe auch immer viel
zwischen Schreibtisch und der Werkstatt
hin und her und wenn ich dann mal am
Laptop was nachschauen muss kann man das
dann instant Weg direkt innerhalb von
einer Sekunde machen und loslegen und
auch wenn ich den Laptop eben hier in
der Werkstatt oder sogar im Zug mobil
ohne Stromkabel benutze ist das mit dem
bis zu 13 Stunden Akkulaufzeit kein
Problem und wenn er mal leer ist kann
man in weniger als 30 Minuten wieder auf
9 Stunden Akkulaufzeit laden aber auch
Gaming ist dank der Insel Iris x Grafik
mit dem starken Intel Core Prozessor der
12 Generation möglich egal ob unterwegs
oder stationär neben dem Lenovo Yoga 7
Pro das ich hier nutze gibt's noch viele
andere Internet Laptops mit
verschiedenen Features wo ihr das
passende Modell für eure Bedürfnisse
aussuchen könnt also
sie mal über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung ab und wir schrauben
jetzt die beiden hier fest genau nach
planen gut also von oben
37,40,8
so das erste Bein passt jetzt von der
Position her das heißt wir bohren jetzt
hier mal die Löcher vor
[Musik]
das ist top ich würde sagen drunter
machen und dann fest gerne für die M10
nehmen
[Musik]
ist voll gut also bei Nummer 3 wird dann
wieder das lange nehmen denn was den wir
jetzt machen der muss das so sein dass
der andere dann am Ende beide berühren
kann aber das kriegen wahrscheinlich
sieht sogar gut aus
machen
[Musik]
und die allerletzte Schraube
da ist es fertig ist eigentlich jetzt
quasi fertig wir müssen das erstmal
zusammenschweißen aber ich würde davor
einfach mal aufstellen okay kannst
ja man muss auf jeden Fall noch die
Beine zusammenschweißen damit das nicht
wackelt
hey das ist richtig gut wollen wir sie
doch richtig gut aus
ey das ist komplett das ist komplett
Plan
[Musik]
weil der Tisch am Schluss bei uns im
Esszimmer stehen soll und Manu das ein
cooles Stück schöner kann als ich
schmeißt Manu die restlichen Beine
zusammen und schaut euch einfach mal an
wie cool das Schweißen in Zeitlupe
aussieht könnte ich mir echt den ganzen
Tag anschauen
[Musik]
gefällt mir so finde ich geil jetzt
müssen die Beine noch lackieren damit
ich nicht verrosten ist Karl Stahl und
dafür brauchen wir die Platz erstmal ab
gar nicht gut glaube
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass dadurch
dass du den jetzt festgeschweißt haben
und dass du vor vielleicht leicht
verspannt war die Schrauben wir jetzt
teilweise halt so fest eingeklemmt sind
dass da überhaupt nichts mehr geht und
jetzt stell mal vor wenn ich jetzt das
die Platte abmache dann verbiegen sich
die wieder wir kriegen nie wieder gerade
hin
[Musik]
was für ein geiles gestellt sieht echt
krass aus
[Musik]
einmal schöne Schutzanzug
also einfach mal sämtliche Fettreste
entfernen die wir drauf gemacht haben
[Musik]
so jetzt ist es trocken und es sieht
mega geil aus ich bin übel überrascht
wie heftig gut das aussieht wir haben
die komplette Metalle Optik erhalten
aber jetzt ist es noch mal viel glatter
durch die Lackschicht und es riecht
nicht mehr so nach Metall und es rostet
halt nicht das geile ist werden
zufälligerweise noch filzkarte
herumliegen genau in der richtigen Größe
dafür und die machen jetzt drauf damit
der Stahl nicht den kompletten Fußboden
kaputt macht
[Musik]
damit ist dieses Gestell hier offiziell
fertig und man kann es auch hinstellen
ohne dass der Boden komplett zerkratzt
wird kaufen kann man sich sowas
ähnliches für 750 €. wir haben nur 78 €
40 für einen Stahl und 17 € 40 für zwei
Schichten Lack bezahlt das heißt ein
bisschen unter 100 €
650 € gespart haben was unfassbar heftig
ist so und mit dem Bauplan zur
anschließend lässt sich Einlassung für
die Heizplatte ähm wir müssen noch
entscheiden wie rum wir machen wollen
ich würde tatsächlich so machen dass die
baumkarte oben ist
mega also wir fräsen jetzt erstmal hier
rein wir haben jetzt diese Schienen hier
das heißt er kann auch nichts schief
gehen eigentlich müssen wir mal machen
gut let's go Rainer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ist das geil also das ist jetzt perfekt
gerade man spielt hier nichts das ist so
komplett präzise sehr sehr geil
[Musik]
also die beiden links und rechts sind
schon mal fertig und das ist so perfekt
das ist richtig krass ich nehme jetzt
einfach nur noch das Zeug da aus der
Mitte Weg
[Musik]
geil also die Spur hat viel besser
geklappt dass ich befürchtet habe
das Stück Metall und das passt
ja richtig gut rein
ich glaube wir kriegen das hier rein und
zwar so das ist genau passt allerdings
ist die Tischplatte in Zentimeter zu
lang haben sie uns geschenkt und das
müssen wir dann später noch absägen
die Frage ist es auf jeden Fall weswegen
ich dich geholt habe wollen wir die
Optik so lassen also wenn es ein
bisschen sauber machen dann wird es
nicht ganz so rot sein oder hättest du
das gerne irgendwie so ein bisschen
hochglänziger also diese Flecken wie
jetzt gar nicht
so dass sie wegkommen ja definitiv aber
sonst finde ich das eigentlich cool dass
das so rustikal ist dann lassen wir das
so
ja also das Ziel ist es jetzt dieses
hässliche rote Zeug weg zu machen auch
genannt Rost
[Musik]
ja ich finde es schon noch leicht
rötlich ich würde noch mal oben vor
allem polieren nun wo die Metallleiste
fertig ist brauchen wir noch einen Weg
wie wir sie aufheizen können weil die
Leiste soll ja nicht nur schön aussehen
sondern auch das Essen in Töpfen und
Pfannen warm halten und dafür kann man
einfach einen elektrischen Widerstand
nehmen und Strom drauf geben ihr habt
mich ja schon mal oft gesehen wie ich so
ein elektrischen Widerstand
verwendetisch äh das egal
Sinn macht aber ich gehe jetzt einfach
mal 18 Volt und vier Ampere soll das
glaube ich gut heiß werden jetzt boah
das ist schon gut waren schnell warm
schön 100 Watt drauf hast Alter das wird
richtig heiß
aber kann damit Aufheizen ist die Frage
ich bitte mal fest
boah ist das heißt
wenn wir das hier ein bisschen drauf
machen
dann zeigt er mir gerade 111 Grad an
natürlich die ganze Platte jetzt nicht
so heiß wenn ich da mal drauf gehe sagte
mir immer noch 50 Grad an und ich glaube
auch 60 70 Grad auch eine gute
Temperatur für seine Warmhalteplatte die
waren halt aber wo man sich eigentlich
verbrennt jo ihr seid jetzt eine heftige
Montage wie Pascal das ganze
funktioniert eine Steuerung verwandelt
dann Display Temperaturregler und
temperatursen
[Musik]
30 cm rausnehmen vielleicht
da drunter
[Gelächter]
komische Geräusche
irgendwo müssen die Heizelement
natürlich auch hin das heißt sie kommen
ja die Unterseite dran das markiere ich
mir erstmal die stellen hier
[Musik]
und da wollen wir jetzt ganz viele
kleine Gewindestangen drin haben damit
wir das irgendwie mit einer Mutter
befestigen können dafür machen wir
einfach mehrere Löcher die ein bisschen
enger sind als die Gewindestange und da
habe ich gerade rausgefunden dass man
die Dinge einfach mit Gewalt reinhängen
kann und sie dann komplett fest sind
also man kriegt überhaupt nicht mehr
raus
da geht überhaupt nichts mehr ohne
schweißen ist es einfach bombenfest ja
dann kann man die Widerstände einfach
schön mit einer Mutter hier festmachen
und dann sind die bombenfest
so meine Plan aufgeht sollte man das
jetzt da drüberlegen können
[Musik]
das passt ja sogar und damit wird das
jetzt einmal festgeschraubt damit die
Metall Leiste oben auch wirklich richtig
fest angezogen wird
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt das was man gemeinhin
die Hochzeit nennt und zack
so sieht jetzt also die fertig
verkabelte Elektronik aus mit dem Regler
kann man einstellen wie warm man die
Platte gerne hätte auf dem Display steht
die aktuelle Temperatur und wenn die
Wunschtemperatur erreicht ist hören die
Widerstände unter der Platte auf zu
heizen und fangen wieder an wenn die
Temperatur zu niedrig wird wodurch die
Temperatur konstant gehalten wird als
finalen Feinschliff wird das Holz noch
mal glatt geschliffen und mit
Hartwachsöl behandelt bevor der Tisch am
nächsten Tag ins Esszimmer kommt wohin
Sophie jetzt zum ersten Mal zu Gesicht
bekommt und
richtig cool aus ist richtig schön der
macht den Raum auch ein bisschen
leichter als unser eigentlicher Tisch
ich finde auch also ich finde auch dass
dadurch dass die Beine hier so dünn sind
nimmt er nicht so viel Raum Weg
irgendwie was halt praktisch ist unser
andere hat ja hier so hier auf der Höhe
ungefähr so Beine und dann ist das voll
kacke wenn du da sitzen übel scheiße das
müssen wir noch ein bisschen Angst dass
die Beine die gehen ja irgendwie voll
zum quer ich hatte ein bisschen Angst
dass man da halt irgendwie den in die
Quere kommt das wollte ich jetzt auch
nämlich als nächstes lassen okay
also ich meine hier kann man schon
dagegen hauen wenn man will aber stört
jetzt nicht normalerweise da sitzt mich
nicht stören was sagst du Stabilität
verschieben kann man es Überraschungen
von dem Tisch auf viel mehr zu den
beiden vorhin stören passend
ja dann komm mal her ich muss nämlich
eine Funktion zeigen so ich habe was
gekocht der Wasser gekocht tatsächlich
und das hat gerade
67,7 Grad genau und wie man das bei
essen will soll das auch so warm bleiben
und nicht einfach kalt werden jetzt habe
ich hier ein krasses Feature dazu möchte
ich mal die Aufmerksamkeit unter den
Tisch lenken ja und jetzt kann man also
hier aufdrehen hier siehst du gerade die
Wunschtemperatur um die aktuelle
Temperatur jetzt drehe ich hier einfach
auf top
komplette Metallding warm es wird nur
ungefähr über das Stück hier waren achso
okay ja gut weil das wäre blöd also hier
ist eiskalt immer smart
also es wird theoretisch bis 100 Grad
gehen
okay das ist also jetzt unser neuer
selbstgebauter Designer Esstisch mit
integrierter heizplattenfunktion den
Link zum Intel Evo Laptop mit dem ich
den tischdes
Laptops findet in der Videobeschreibung
und ich bin damit raus